(Crew talking on set)
(Violin music swells)
You're in sports casual.
I'm in costume.
(Laughter)
-Do you work with Jackson Lamb?
-Yeah.
-What’s he like?
(Violin sting)
It's quite exciting to come back
ready for more
in this season of Slow Horses.
-Yeah, coming back was a real joy.
It was a delight
to see all the old faces.
It becomes like it's a family.
-Yeah.
-This is Soho.
Well, where’s all the
prostitutes and the junkies?
-Soho’s changed.
-Shut up Mike.
-Marcus.
-How would you characterize
Lamb and River’s relationship
throughout the course of the show?
-It's sort of tough love with...
...with River because I see potential.
Right, so what do I do then?
-Piss off to the
job center for all I care.
-The way he is with everybody.
It's not malicious. It's not nasty.
I've met people like that,
and so have you, that when they find
someone they think is very good,
they’re particularly hard on them.
-And they ride ‘em harder, don’t they?
-Like hell.
-Yeah.
I mean, where I come
from, if you take the piss
that much of someone,
that is a mark of respect.
-Absolutely.
-Genuine affection is the worst thing
you can do to another human being.
(Laughter)
-If you uncovered the trail
that quickly, it couldn't
have been that well hidden.
Thanks.
(Crunching)
-I've learned
a ridiculous amount from you.
-You have?
-A ridiculous amount.
-One of my favorite
things was, as an actor,
watching you work the scene out
and get halfway through and go,
“Nah, that doesn't work”
and not lose the head.
Be like,
“I'll find it at some point.”
-Yeah.
Like people should sell tickets
to that kind of stuff.
-Action!
-I'm very impressed
by how confident you are.
Even if I know it
all might be...
-It’s bollocks.
-An act,
-Yeah.
-You appear to be
confident and relaxed.
-You're right, he's definitely onto me.
-Are you sure?
-Yeah.
-You‘ll want to get closer.
This season is,
in part, a revenge story.
-Yeah.
And it's gonna work. Gangbusters.
-Right.
Although, we
shouldn't give too much away.
-He was following
someone when he died.
Maybe he saw something
that he shouldn't have.
-And, why has Slough House
been dragged into this?
We’re nobodies.